hi it's day 30 so were officially one
third of the way through today I had
actually a good day and so far studying
Korean is concerned I was able to put in
about I don't know four plus hours a
good portion of it was reading on my
computer and a bit on my iPad while
listening and sort of going ahead as I'm
listening going ahead to the yellow
words that saved before and looking them
up in case I didn't know what what they
meant and just kind of kind of you know
drill that language into me because I
have so much trouble understanding when
I listen and when I read I press I can
slowly pick my way through it because
I'm looking words up and so I make great
sense of it all but when I listen I have
trouble so I want to do a lot of
listening listening to content that I've
worked over before listening while
reading I want to just slowly get my
brain used to this language what strikes
me today as I work through this is that
first of all language learning you know
it takes a lot of work people who talk
about three months whatever from zero
the fluent stuff it's it's unless it's a
very similar language it takes a lot of
work and for the simple reason that that
there are so many words to learn I think
that is the biggest problem it's it's
not so much the grammar it takes a while
you use the grammar yes but there are so
many words to learn if I look at my
Korean the number of words that I've
learned and yet the number of new words
that crop up all the time and and as you
come across them and I save them and
Link you know what sometimes wonder like
how am I ever gonna learn on these all
these words there's just so many of them
but again I know from experience that if
I get enough exposure that I will learn
them and because time is limited you
know I don't want to spend two hours
going through flashcards I will go
through flashcards every now and again
if I have 15 minutes there 20 minutes
here I'm waiting somewhere but the 3-4
hours that I had today I can't imagine
spending food for hours on five
but 3-4 hours listening reading reading
again listening again getting that sense
of the flow of the language to me that's
a better place for me to spend my time
but still the task is enormous there are
so many words to learn yet words are the
key and you know if I think of the
people who impressed me as speakers of
foreign languages it's not people who
pronounce like a native to me that's
almost irrelevant in fact if you have
too much of a native like pronunciation
and you don't have the words to back it
up it almost sounds strange whereas if I
listen to someone someone like Thomas
Bach who is the the I think is the head
of the Internet International Olympic
Committee he replaced this fellow wrong
could raw egg and he made two speeches
in Sochi at the opening of the Olympic
Games he spoke in English and he spoke
in French and he was tremendously
eloquent in both and he used a lot of
words but you knew that he knew these
words because he didn't read he spoke
and he spoke very very well and yet he
has an unmistakable German accent and it
doesn't matter what matters is his
control of words so to me the big
challenge in language learning is words
words and phrases if you want because
it's words and how they work with other
words and which words belong together
with other words and for this particular
shade of meaning it's this word not that
word and all of these things require a
lot of exposure a lot of practice and
it's the biggest task and that's why to
get from to get to sort of advance the
beginner where you can say a few things
is almost the easy part of the journey
to get from there to where you are a
very proficient user of the language is
a long long journey primarily because of
the words and that's kind of the message
today it's a long task you know I don't
underestimate the amount of time and
effort that's required for anyone and
the biggest hurdle is acquiring all the
necessary words and developing that
sense of context of when to use which
words
and so then not only to use them but to
understand them because as we know we
need to have an even broader range of
passive vocabulary so that we can
understand what people are saying words
that's the big burden but the challenge
and to my mind discovering a new word is
fun so it's in a way it's the term it's
the treasure hunt of language learning